[Music]
love that song all right
it's a good song love that sweat to me
is a different song
right this is my whole entire point is
that you take the most obscure song
not that there's anything wrong with
that you just have a different i mean
listen i understand what
okay we're live i just want you know if
you just joined us this is the 25th
podcast episode we're doing if the last
15 minutes were live
this would be a bad situation if the
last 15 minutes we're live we're having
a little too much fun
adam uh telling us his uh uh uh pickup
lines
which may be for a different uh
different uh episode that we'll do
anyways um
we have a lot to cover today a lot of
crazy things happen last two days um
i'm gonna show a video i did about
voting just so you know
where my values and principles lie this
is a video i did
april of 2014. all right okay on how i
felt about the voting system and how i
think we should change the voting system
we'll get a chance to watch it hopefully
on 1.5 just still relevant
i think i think it's important because
some of the stuff i was watching myself
i'm like okay that's extreme
this is but it's good to see it to kind
of see what happens
you're about to i think you'll see when
you see where i was at at that time but
i actually liked what he had to say
what the 35 year old pvd had to say i
actually liked what he had to say i like
that guy he's a good guy
he's a good guy okay we're going to talk
about age ages like what
what ages do we get to do certain things
in america being a president being a
vice president
senate house sexual consent smoking
alcohol i guarantee you some of you guys
are going to
learn numbers about age and consent
certain things that you
never thought were legal we're going to
talk about today
alibaba's singles singles day that they
had
they had a decent day we'll let you know
how that compares against uh
amazon bill ackman makes another massive
bet
on newt co new covet 19 search the last
time he made this bet
kai the last time he made that bait he
made a lot of money but he's doing it
again and this time around he's double
and down billionaire you'll see where
he's going with it
pfizer ceo the day after they announced
the vaccine
you will not believe what he did with
his shares
the day after they announced the vaccine
i mean it's shocking
when you find out what is seriously it's
shocking when you find that
and i'm curious to know your thoughts
about it ammunition backlog over a
billion dollars adam's been concerned
every day lately have you guys noticed
that
adam's been complaining about ammunition
backlog yeah okay
mine's on back order for months now i
got to get my guns
i need 10 more that's why he got his num
chucks out
you need ten more guys no no no adam's
gonna get away with anything
by just being charming and smooth listen
i don't think it's a good idea for you
to shoot me right now because
you want to live a long life and enjoy
listen you know don't you want to do i
gotta tell me to tell you the day that
you shoot me and kill me you will die
the next day
this is what happens that's exactly the
land that's based on karma man
what is it episode three or two i think
that's one of them we talked about
genius right premonition
governor abbott welcomes major stock
exchange to us the nasdaq they're having
conversations right now
kai did you get the story about
california newsom on what new york and
california is doing is it in there or no
is it in here when i go to it okay
georgia's doing a recount but by hand
uh biden's uh uh buddy is saying that we
should shut down the economy for six
weeks which is a brilliant idea
obviously
tesla selling to tequila bottles for
250.
uh where is that article that's the
article i want to really talk about the
one that talks about
uh uh let me see where you have it
nearly 80
americans say biden one white house
ignoring trump's refusal to concede
that's reuters which is uh
it's a big number we'll talk about that
as well uh i do not see
where you have that kai is it under
politics
what top of the page where it starts
with the republic can you read it you
just read it
you're talking about you're looking for
the 80 number no no i'm talking about
how
california and new york are telling you
how to celebrate thanksgiving oh i
haven't seen have you seen that it's
absolutely berserk oh there's only a
limited
you don't have it here i'm talking about
my governor be careful
i apologize oh it's at the bottom of the
page where it says politics but we'll
get into it i want
to be a page bottom of the page politics
matter of fact i i don't mind getting
into that but i think it's a good idea
we get into
thanksgiving oh let me see here i want
to get into that right off the bat
anyways why don't we get into uh
okay i don't have it here if you haven't
start the story off with telling
everybody why you look so fresh this
morning oh i look so fresh this morning
because uh
i uh woke up this morning i said i don't
know why i just want to look good for
adam today it's just a commitment i made
to myself you know why don't you do that
for me every day anymore i just
i do it every day sometimes it's a white
t-shirt sometimes it's white shoes
it's pretty consistent let's talk about
looking fresh tom brooke the kangol
breaking it back to the 80s you know
what he's doing when i don't have to
spend any time on my hair it saves me 10
minutes that's awesome 10 minutes wow so
minimum so so let's get into it alibaba
let's start off with business
alibaba okay all we think about is and
hear about is amazon amazon amazon
amazon amazon right it's all we hear
about and we talk about amazon all the
time
if you want to give it to me if you have
that alibaba's
single day that they have is that yours
or mine okay yeah alibaba singles day
which is
amazon's prime day right alibaba's
singles day post virus
ends up doing 56 billion
dollars let me say that one more time
singles day
does 56 billion dollars in a day
amazon for their prime day this year
they did
3.5 billion dollars 3.5 billion versus
56 billion dollars we're talking 16
times is what they did
uh singles day was created by alibaba
exec jackman daniel zhang
as a foil to valentine's day the date
11-11 was picked because it looks like
bear branches single and unattached
we feel even lonelier now alibaba kicked
off
sales a little earlier this year as of
12 30 30 a.m local time consumers spent
56.3 billion dollars
uh on products to move all the products
around alibaba's logistics arm prepared
3 000 chartered flights
and cargo ships 3 million logistic
workers and 10
000 mobile lockers to get this done what
do you think about i mean
yeah the legislation is six billion
against three point five billion yeah
you know what i don't begrudge these
guys how rich they are insane
you know bezos and in jack by the way
how is jack ma
only worth 40 billion
dollars you know when you see a picture
of jack you kind of get the idea why
uh he wasn't getting a lot of dates on
valentine's day and he had to create
this
but hey i'm sure he's getting dates now
though oh my god can you imagine
hey here's a little fun fact about um
guys 4-8 about uh
singles day just the amount of bras they
sold on the first day
1.6 million bras how would you get if
you stacked him up it would be three
times higher than mount everest
isn't that unbelievable that's a lot of
bras to move in china
you know they sold 1.6 million broads
just on the first day
and i think this is i think this hit 100
billion you know because they do it
longer it's more than just one day
they go and go and go i think it's a
great sign that the economy is strong
if china china where they started the
virus
you know is doing this well with their
economy is a good sign but it also
reflects on the fact that
the pandemic people are shopping from
home more those are staggering numbers
the logistics of what you just talked
about the amount of planes and how these
guys coordinate this thing
we get ticked off if our amazon delivery
is 15 minutes late
can you imagine what's going on in these
warehouses where they have to like
you know that maybe that's why it's so
hard to work for amazon and they run
such a tight ship but
i think it's staggering i think it's
unbelievable and i hope uh i hope it's a
sign of
of good things for the economy if
china's having this much success
always reassuring when there's 1.5
million bra selling it's always a good
thing but what are your thoughts about
this
numbers a lot of titties are being
thanked on um
singles day protected yeah protected
good for them i mean
speaking of jack ma what was the big
news from him
last week that he launched the the
largest ever ipo
ever well exactly well the uh the ant
group
i'm not sure necessarily sure it flopped
is that was that was that what the uh
what do you mean the final news would
flop
what i what actually happened what
happened i'm asking it didn't happen it
didn't happen no
he was launching
how did his wealth go from 400 uh uh 40
billion to 100 billion overnight then i
thought
it's called your company that's 56
billion it's all because of the alibaba
the list came out yesterday he's now on
the list of 100 billion 100 billion
dollar net worth
it's him it's gates i think it's zuck
it's musk
and i'm uh one other one i'm missing one
other one musk zuck
gates no it's the renault guy it's the
it's the louis vuitton what is that oh
yeah
i don't know my god by the way how high
will that get in our lifetime will we
see somebody at 500
higher you think basically in our life
in our life you think we'll see a
trillionaire
in our lifetime who's the youngest he's
40 so let's just he lives in 90 he's
healthy he takes care of himself
uh 50 years and 50 years i think we'll
we could see a trillion
in 50 years but there's also a good
chance that biden gets reelected
if he gets elected for the first time
that uh bezos could be a millionaire
well that's a that's an interesting one
right there it'll take a it'll take more
time i think it'll take aoc for him to
be a millionaire
we need an aoc form to be a millionaire
i think biden's not going to make him a
millionaire anyways
uh okay if you're watching this and
you're enjoying it why don't you share
this with others and uh push a thumbs up
for uh our buddies at youtube to uh for
the algorithms to kick in
uh uh because i know we're just getting
warmed up here with the stories i really
want to get into this california new
york story but i think
we we lead into it let's hang tight for
it let's talk about bill ackman here
let's talk about bill ackman and we'll
go into the vaccine situation
so bill ackman billionaire made another
massive bet
on the new covet 19 surge i hope we lose
money on the next
hedge ackman told the financial times
conference on tuesday we're in a
treacherous time
generally and what's fascinating is the
same bet we put on eight months ago
is available on the same is available on
the same uh
terms as if there had never been a fire
and a depart
on the probability that the world is
going to be fine bill ackman just
placed another big bet against the
credit markets as coronavirus cases
surge nationwide
the billionaire has invest has said he
bought eight million dollars worth of
insurance that will pay off
if company starts defaulting on their
debts like they did
when the coronavirus shut down the
economy in the spring the bet is nearly
identical
his now famous hedge in late march in
which he turned he bought
27 million dollars of credit default
swap cds which is what they used to do
in
the movie the big short right he bought
a 27 million credit default swap
that netted him a staggering you ready
he bought 27 million dollars
in march that turned it into 2.6 billion
dollars
is what he did he's banking on the
economy taking a hit
when ackman took his profits on march
23rd there were just over 10 000 new
cases of covet 19 nationwide
on tuesday new cases were just shy of
140 000 a dizzying number that has
stoked fears of a second lockdown what
are your thoughts on this his biggest
thing was
you know he came out in mid-march
pre-lockdown i mean what was the big
event that happened that the world was
like or america was like holy what's
going on
the nba lockwood yes or nba and when the
nba shut down everyone's like what the
hell is going on here that was like i
think march
yeah that was the whole thing maybe give
or take
fair enough yeah that's he came out i
want to say march 15
16 17 right like second week in march
and he basically
is the first thing he said is hell is
coming it was like the lead story on
cnbc
uh hedge fund billionaire bill ackman
has announced hell is coming
and basically called on trump for a
lockdown this is pre-full-on lockdown
and the dominoes fell and and clearly
the guy was right because
kovitt exploded at that point he placed
the the correct bet
is has been called the what the single
best trade of all time and this is what
a hedge fund guy does right i mean
you buy 7 million into 2.6 billion that
quickly that's insane do you think
there's something
shady going on there no i'm not i'm just
thinking it's a great move you know yeah
yeah i saw something coming obviously
here's the deal i mean
stay in your lane though bro i mean you
know you don't need to be telling the
president what to shut down okay if you
want to get rich
you're an opportunist you're brilliant i
have no problem with that whatsoever
here's here's the problem i have he his
quote after this latest round of
shorting he goes i hope we lose money
yeah right okay don't be disingenuous
about it i mean you're in it to make
money if you're so concerned about hey i
don't want this virus to take off and
more people
to die and get sick and and blah blah
blah then donate the money you made the
first time
okay you're a capitalist you want to
make the money you got the opportunity
say i hope we make another three billion
don't be like this
okay it makes it seem like both sides he
wants to be nice but also make a couple
he's protecting himself yeah you know
what i also i also don't like the fear
that he's thrown out there too oh it's
coming it's coming back in march when he
made that first bet
there was only 10 000 cases are there
more than that now
has it gone up i haven't seen the latest
stats are there still ten thousand
no i'm joking it's like you know
wonderful millions away um
so anyway you know it's going to work
this the timing for him is perfect if
biden holds on to this
it's it's all setting up for him he bet
this time he put on how much to some
eight million
is that all he did so he didn't go 27
million again
correct i don't know okay this one is 30
percent as big as the last one i think
yeah thirty percent eight million yeah
exactly what are you doing just if you
just put another 27 if 27 turned into
two points he's not as confident
yeah that so eight that eight million if
it did the same thing it would turn into
800 million dollars
that's what it would do that eight
million to 800 800 100 x your money
in the span of a couple months
money the first time around imagine
going doing that again in the space but
i tell you i think if he's going from 27
to 8 i don't think he's as confident
about the fact that he
uh it's going to be as bad if you're
that confident you would put 54.
you would put 100 what's up you just
made 2.6 billion once you put 100 of it
who cares what's 100.
you know here's my biggest problem with
it though because okay he's successful
doing this it's working a lot of people
have seen the big short movie
there's gonna be a lot of people jealous
that they didn't think of this that have
the ability to do it that are in the
financial
world what's to stop them from creating
a frenzy that another wave is coming so
they can make a billion dollars because
the media will run with it
they love these stories that the country
has fallen apart is ready to shut down
again that the covet virus is taking
over everything so
watch for that because there's going to
be a lot of people that are jealous they
didn't think of it if you're watching us
what do you think about it what do you
think about a guy betting 27 million
bucks to turn into
2.6 billion right afterwards what are
your thoughts is that okay
are you comfortable with that i'm
curious if you're watching this comment
below but let's get into the next story
the next story to me it's uh
i mean guys this is very weird
pfizer ceo announces the vaccine
cashes out 60 of his stock on the same
day the company unveiled
the results of its covet 19 vaccine
trial let me say this one more time this
is not a typo
pfizer ceo cashes out 60 of his stock on
the same day the
company unveiled the results of its
covet 19 vaccine trial
so they announced the vaccine how it did
the 90 percent
efficacy all the stats that they gave us
and he sells 60
of the stock on the sim wouldn't you
keep it if you think the company is
going to be going up
wouldn't you be thinking if the market
responded disney went up everything went
up except for
those zoom stocks the companies that
were relying on the pandemic to stick
around
albert barola sold 62 of a stock on the
same day
the drug maker announced the kova 19
vaccine trial borola sold 5.6 million
dollars of a stock on monday as part of
his predetermined trading plan
adopted august 19 his stock sale was
carried out at 41.94 cents a share the
52 week high for pfizer was 41.99 so 5
cents less
which means the ceo cash that is shares
at close to their highest price this
year
pfizer and his german partner bio and
tech on monday became the first to post
positive results
from late stage covet 19 vaccine trials
i mean
he has to know when he makes this move
that it's going to hit the
the media and they're going to run with
it so i'm sure he has some sort of
excuse well you got to understand here's
what i was doing
here's the thing but as far as optics
goes this looks like the classic case of
insider trading right i mean this is has
insider trading
not even so much insider he knew this
was going down and he just exited i mean
he
it hit the first time what it was the
first it was a high for the year
4194 he sold it 41.99 and he just got
out
i mean what what more could there be
other than
insider trading here you know i got two
thoughts on this number one
like you said it was predetermined in
august that he was going to do this but
number one i'm suspicious about
everything regarding the timing of this
announcement
politically all right when it came out
you know just conveniently a few days
after the election how it happens to
help one individual and then you know
how this breaks that day but here's the
other thought i had when i heard that he
made five million dollars on this
whole more than 5 million he sold 45
5.6 million yeah 5.6 million holy crap
is he underpaid
for developing the vaccine that is going
to stop a pandemic
he is only making five million okay
remember when everybody was talking
about bill gates you know kind of like
manipulating this whole thing
wanting to be involved and finding the
vaccine to make
billions how do you only make 5.6
million for coming up
with the vaccine to stop covid19 i think
he should have made 10 times that
to come out with that vaccine yes yes
you know hey look he he did it he was
the first one out to market
i there's no way he could be that stupid
to come out and you know
to to do anything that could get him in
trouble financially but so sometimes
these deals because it says here
uh he sold 5.6 million in stock on
monday as part of his predetermined
trading plan adopted august 19. so
on august 19th they didn't know
that the market was going to or pfizer
was going to announce the vaccine on
this specific day so was that a
predetermined date that they were going
to sell it on this specific
day or could he have sold it later on
because if you're optimistic
about the fact that the vaccine is going
to do very well isn't it fair to say
that pfizer stock is about to blow up
yeah and if fights or stocks about to
blow up and go from 41.94 a share which
is what he sold
if it's going to go to 80 that's what
that's
12 million dollars for him if it goes to
that's 24 million dollars for him why is
he cashing out of 5.6 now here's the
other thing it seems very
sometimes when you see this maybe
there's a divorce going on where the
wife is forcing to
sell shares because you have to pay the
other half but that's not it this is a
predetermined this has got nothing to do
with personal life this is a contract
monday as part of a predetermined
trading plan adopted august 19th okay i
got two thoughts on yeah maybe in august
they didn't know they'd be first to get
out
okay so that's what i'm saying yeah
that's what i'm saying and the other
thing too is there might be a bonus for
him
if they were first he gets 10 million
new shares
you know that he can hold on to now and
watch the stock price rise so
i'm sure there's some sort of incentive
for him as the ceo for them to be first
i'll tell you i mean if you're ceo think
about it adam you're a ceo you're ceo of
pfizer
okay and you decided to work with pfizer
because they have great product blue
pills whatever they got but let's just
say you're
you're a ceo pfizer okay and
you know more than anybody else that
your vaccine is about to come out
you know all the testing you've done you
know what's coming out
and you know what kind of a blockbuster
announcement's going to be if you're
going to be the what
first pfizer is going to be on every
single paper times post
washington new york la everything is
going to say five surprise or fights
pfizer ceo for one day is the most
famous man in the world and one day he's
the most famous man in the world
you didn't know the name albert borla
as of the day before they announced it
you didn't know the hell no okay
nobody knew the name now except for the
people in the industry knew the name but
most people didn't know the name you
know this is coming up
aren't you having a conversation with
the guys who say look can i hang on to
my shares do i have to sell my shares
can i not sell my shares can i sit on
these shares
can i just hang tight because the
scariest thing is when somebody's
putting a bet on uh
when you're going through a transaction
and let's just say you want to sell
something
sometimes the buyer will ask you do you
want to keep some of the shares yourself
if you say no i want to sell 100 of the
shares but i'm really optimistic about
this business guess what the buyer says
how are you optimistic where you want to
sell 100 but if you say no i'm cool
i'll let her roll a little bit what does
a buyer say okay good he's also
vested with us he's got skin in the game
i mean he's keeping some of it but
wouldn't you keep the shares for another
six months
sixty-two percent of his stock i
actually agree with tom here 5.6 million
nothing
yeah i think very low listen that's my
idea i was like well he's made more than
five
exactly well you got to realize ceos
don't make as much money as you think
founders do okay ceo's not the same as a
founder especially
in europe they're not like americans
unless if you're a ceo of tim cook apple
things like that different story but
you know the gravy train is not going to
stop for him for a long time couple
reasons why uh a do you know that when
we get the vaccine we're talking about
will you get the shot
yeah it's two shots all right it's not
just one you have to go back
and do another shot in three weeks this
is a two-part deal and the other thing
too is
i saw a story today where the vaccine
they're hoping is going to last for a
year
so this thing is going to be around for
much longer than a year so pfizer if
they're the first ones out there
if they can prove this thing and people
trust it they trust this vaccine and
it's working the testing all
all shakes out i mean you know that it's
going to be raining on him for a very
long time
i mean that you're saying the vaccine is
only going to last a year
well more than likely no no no yeah the
vaccine is going to last yeah so then
you're gonna have to get it again if
it's just like the solution
every year so then it becomes a
continuous thing we do until this thing
goes away and
uh we don't have it anymore that's the
same thing as a flu shot right i mean
you don't get it once and you're done
it's by the way you mentioned
we had never heard of that ceo when you
google pfizer ceo sell stock that phrase
59 million hits come up exactly that's
how many people checked him out into
that store
that's exactly the point so imagine as
of the day prior to that nobody knew
they next or 59 million people are
searching this guy's name
but that goes back to my initial point
he has to have a story to tell
knowing that this is going to be the
breaking news that comes but here's the
other thing too
it's brilliant because what are we
talking about here the election results
something like this if something
nefarious was going on
could kind of slide under the cracks a
little bit because people are so
desperate to find this
this vaccine and have something on the
market that's working and we're talking
about biden versus i actually
i actually don't know if there's
anything nefarious going i i'm just
thinking myself that this is just a
you know if if it's if it's contracted
that you have to sell on that day
he's screwed so if it's something that
he had to sell it on that same day
he's sitting around saying [ __ ] i wish i
could keep this for another three more
months
or six months right so if he could have
negotiated a grade if he couldn't have
and he sold it then i don't know if it's
a good move or not so
the bottom line is if it's predetermined
trading yeah they say
on august 19th you have to sell on
november 10th that's the yeah that's
that's what happens
so then the big question is could the
announcement have come a day later
or did it come on that date for him to
capitalize on a higher
15 raised stock price let me tell you if
this vaccine takes off for pfizer that
41 is going to go to 80 in no time guys
don't forget what happened to zoom we
didn't even
know know about we knew about zumba but
we didn't know about zuma and all of a
sudden
shares went from 60 bucks to 500 in six
months yeah you know what 60 to 500
that's like saying this 41 is gonna go
to
350 dollars in the next six months you
know what's 350
if this thing goes to 350 that's nearly
9x you know it's 9x a 5.6 million that's
a 15 that's a 50 million dollar payday
sure 45 million dollar payday he left 40
million on the table
i would actually be pissed that i had
that's what i'm saying if he had to sell
so i'm reversing course on this this guy
should actually probably want to hold on
to this
all right we'll see there is something
shady going on i am sure it's going to
come out in the next few days but if not
man if it's if it wasn't a contract a
little bit of a bad time like a case of
reverse
insider trading yeah yeah like it's
screwed on it are you saying this is
this is called outsider training is that
what you would call it
all right well he's on the inside so so
let's let's talk about let's talk about
california
new york let's let's talk about
california new york two of the coolest
governors we got in america that uh you
know uh
the other day i don't know if you heard
what the new news not news um cuomo said
cuomo said i'd like if i wasn't a
governor i'd love to
deck him in the face i'd love to yeah
cuomo said this about trump said what
was the country
wait you didn't see this no cuomo said
have you seen this or no
see if you can find it cuomo punch trump
go to youtube and type in cuomo punch
trump
pat what was that country accent you
just used for new york it was like a
buffalo accent because it's definitely
not in new york i thought it had like
alabama make some threats over here
cuomo punch trump go up he just made
that allegation this is
do do filter filter it out by a week
filter it out by week this week left
left
left right there weak uh let's see
andrew punching trump in the face yeah
there you go
uh uh dude uh uh do the 53 second one
and i hope you know okay do the 53
second one right there
reaction to what it said and then fast
forward
to end tonight on andrew cuomo the
governor of new york
trying to be the most masculine cuomo on
television he announced he was thinking
about
punching donald trump this year sounds
pretty tough right punching the
president united states right in the
face
and he would have done it if he hadn't
inherited his father's job as governor
watch i needed him
to help new york meeting trump that was
my job
if i wasn't governor of new york i would
have decked him
uh period i mean he was attacking me he
was attacking my family he was the
anti-italian he was
every nasty thing you know you if i
take away that word governor for 24
hours i would have had a field day with
him
he's on a route he's on steroids look at
his face
that's a roid rage oh my gosh that's
just hilarious but a part of that to me
is new york
the the attitude of new york uh uh for
him to say something like that
i didn't say he'd punch him in the face
though he's able to deck them what does
decta mean you tell me what deck to me
put him on a dick and have a cup of
coffee
what is decked to you it could have been
in the chest it could have been in the
nuts it could have been a kneecap he
could have told
there is a phrase called you're reaching
you are fully reaching right now buddy
what the hell is this i'm gonna punch
you i've never seen
you know what my son say what when they
punch each other they punch
and they aim at one place right face
face what do you mean i'm gonna raise
the fighters i'm gonna kick you in the
shin
let me punch you in your shoulders do
you have a problem with him saying that
i have no problem with him saying that
trump said way worse than that but i'd
punch him right in the face he said
100 times did i tell you have a problem
with them i know you're protective of
your community did i say have a problem
with that i'm just protective of the
fighting community
i mean i'm trying to have uh ufc going
oh my gosh i've never heard anybody say
deck
he didn't say he's gonna deck him into
the fight
i don't know he wants a pillow fire ufc
if somebody says i'm gonna deck him all
of you in here what does he mean i'm
going to deck him louise what is that
okay
does it mean face or shoulder eric
honestly punch in the face
punch in the face i mean even norway
what is i'm gonna do
what are you are you gonna try normally
nobody doesn't dig people right
face okay
was expecting him to be like i'd smack
him right in the kiss or something
something like straight up in the face
this is the kind of stuff you say while
your sober community grows
it's coming like that you make that your
community gets more loyal to you
i wish you would have said something a
little more like a mother like this yeah
i thought i just wanted to see something
like that i'm just saying the way that
we built it up i thought oh [ __ ] he's
about to say something here off camera
off record i guarantee he said what you
want him to say
you're not what i want him to say what i
thought he was going here's the craziest
thing let me tell you guys the craziest
thing that
many people think i'm crazy for this i
love
watching him and his brother on camera
together yeah i can't even tell you that
i can i can already see like you know
you i have a lot of friends who are on
all sides politically
i have muslim friends god people think
i'm muslim half the time i have to
explain on
instagram i'm from iran oh you know love
to the muslim community and i'm like i'm
not
i hate to disappoint you but i was born
and raised in iran right yeah i got
people from all sides
can you imagine thanksgiving at the
cuomo's actually think about that
i actually think thanksgiving at the
cuomo's would be so
entertaining keeping everybody is
talking [ __ ]
taking shots yeah you know like you do
this you're this fan
what are you talking about all you did
is being a governor you're on tv you
working hour day they're non-stop well
they're hilarious the governor had a
funny line when he was talking about all
his sisters and he included chris into
that right did you hear that the other
day he lumped him into his group sisters
because i got all these sisters
including chris so that was pretty funny
you know here's the other thing too do
not bet against the fact that when
donald if donald trump doesn't prevail
in this election which he still might
um if he doesn't if he doesn't
could i could see him setting up a
pay-per-view him against cuomo
i could see the fight i could see it
happening he's gonna fight
trump versus cuomo trump will put it on
pay-per-view cuomo would kick the [ __ ]
out of that guy you're kidding
you don't think a height advantage means
something in a brawl six
four versus five three or whatever it is
five three three five five
he might be fine you know what hitting
me he's soft he lives up in
where's the capital of new york
schenectady richard
rochester it's not even new york city
he's not even in a big city
andrew andrew oh he's five eleven five
eleven six he's five three and he's uh
he's reaching over here by the way let's
just see some of these chris cuomo is
six two by three tucker carlson six one
cooper is five ten he's not five ten
i've seen
he there's no way in the world anderson
cooper's uh 510. uh uh pelosi five five
uh uh
apparently everybody on google is two
inches taller these are lies across the
board
don lemon's five nine he is not six feet
barron trump seven four this is
ridiculous
who is this guy that's you saying it but
he's my guy so anyways let's get let's
by the way if you're watching this if
you're watching i guarantee hang on a
second
if if trump donald trump senior fought
cuomo andrew cuomo new york governor who
would win the fight
thumbs up trump trump wins thumbs down
cuomo wins i'm actually curious thumbs
up trump wins cuomo hang on
yeah cuomo wins now how will just give
the ages give the ages
how old is andrew cuomo andrew coleman
i'm going to say he's probably 65.
how old do you think he is yeah he's in
his mid to late sixties he's 62 years
old he's ten years younger than trump
he's not he's better
he's not in good shape trump said we
thought he was our seventh trump is 74.
what does trump say twelve years you
know what what are you talking about hey
by the way before this fight that they
have i would demand a drug test
because i guarantee you he's on groids
cuomo that was a roar
on roy's how do you think he beat the
coven so quickly were you talking about
listen listen we went from politics to
steroids
we've had plenty of steroids coming
you're talking about decade people in
the face pat which way would direction
we go in here listen decking people in
the shoulder
they would never i'm going to take you
right in your shin cap
i'm going to deck you right in your
chest cavity he said he would deck him
in his shoulder not the face
listen okay all right so let's check
this out trump would pump that fight
though she would hype it up that would
be pretty good he would hype it up but
check this out by the way for the right
pay do you think he would do it for the
right for the right penalty you can't
rule it out
he's gonna owe a couple hundred million
uh bucks when he leaves office yeah he's
gonna need the money
anyways by the way i think it would be a
terrible fight i think it would be one
of the worst fights of all time to watch
stefan it would be a
horrible fight you know all these like
what do you call these
exhibition fights they do they all suck
they're terrible
they're not real [ __ ] up how tall was
mike tyson by the way five ten five
eleven
okay same height as uh as our guy cuomo
here you know
have you seen tyson's thighs do you know
what tyson's thighs look like yeah they
look like ice and dylan bet david's size
exactly tyson's ties are nuts you know
that that quickness with the
you know the hip flex anyways all right
let's talk about thanksgiving so
thanksgiving is around the corner folks
if you live in new york in california
we have to warn you you have to do
thanksgiving right if you live in new
york and california so you cannot screw
this thing up because people are going
to come to your house
and some bad things could happen kai do
you want to pull up what the guidelines
are
for do you have both new york and
california
okay so you want me to read all of this
i needed like a basic one-pager so
here's
here's huh
i'm still trying to find it buddy i'm
telling you the point is there's a lot
of freaking rules
okay so ladies and gentlemen that's kyle
over there all right here we go here we
go so this is california is this new
york high the first one you're giving me
okay california three household max
limit
must gather outdoors social distancing
must take place
you must wear masks between bites and
drinking
less than two hours no singing or
shouting
this is your thanksgiving in california
let me read this one more time by the
way this
is from their website this is not a joke
when i saw this i said it's for sure a
joke let me read this
again are you guys hearing this i'm
flabbergasted by this
so you can have a maximum three
household maximum limit
okay must gather that includes your
house limits you can only have
two house loans so you bring your mom
dad kids that's it
two more i can have two more of those
must gather outdoors
not indoor social distancing must take
place
you must wear masks in between bites and
drinking
less than two hours is what you can
spend time with your family look at the
look on your face
no singing or shouting what do you mean
no singing
or shouting can you control f to see if
that is bs that it says no
right there rules were singing chanting
shouting outdoor gathering sending
chanting shouting and physical exertion
significantly
increases the risk of coveting
because these activities increase the
release of respiratory droplets and fine
aerosols into the air because of this
singing chanting and shouting are
strongly discouraged but if they all
occur
the following rules and recommendations
apply all people who are singing or
chanting should wear a mask
covering at all times while singing or
chan including anyone who is leading a
song or chant
hence they're talking about the church
because these activities pose a very
high risk of covet 19 transmission phase
what coverings
are essential to reduce the spread of
respiratory droplets and ever so i mean
this has got to be pathetic right
by the way that's california so let me
get your reaction for some california go
ahead okay by the way playing of wind
instruments is strongly discouraged
okay go back to case you're you're you
know a mad jazz flute
aficionado um
you know listen this is funny to a point
but these are
actual elected officials who spent a
great
deal of time on this i'm petrified for
the future of california
and new york and i am not joking these
people will
subtly like little surgeons little
psycho surgeons is all they are
one step at a time normalize it oh we're
not gonna let you sing
oh you know take a bite of stuffing put
your mask back on
chew quietly don't sing don't go to
church these guys are serious
about jacking all our freedoms and
that's not a conspiracy theory
if they went through that much time to
write in that great of detail
they're sick people there's something
wrong with that
i mean it's so anti-american on every
single level
and it speaks to fear and it speaks
speaks to panic
and it speaks to we know what's best for
you let us protect you every second of
the day
these are your people tom in california
these are your people how do you live
there how do you i don't
know i don't know you've lived there for
how long six years
when are you getting out of there man
enough's enough it's it's
it's unbelievable it truly is
unbelievable the other day no i'm
serious
i'm being serious like when is enough
enough that you're going to leave well i
think we've hit that point
so you're out well look i'm not here to
make any big announcements but i mean
how much more can you take i can't take
anymore um
the other day i mean you guys saw this
that one city council member in los
angeles wants to turn the la convention
center
right next to the staples center into a
homeless shelter
by the way there's no showers there's
limited bathrooms um when there's no can
by the way every day at the convention
center is booked for the next five years
how are you just going to truck all the
homeless could you imagine what they
would do to the convention center
it would be destroyed it would be done
garcetti says
i need a little bit more data on this
but i think for the time being we'll
keep them in four-star hotels
because they do take over hotels and
just move them right in
sick you know it's unbelievable same
thing in new york moving to california
why would you want to leave california
you get a free hotel
yeah these uh these things are obviously
a freaking joke
these rules this is not a budget i wish
it was a joke i get that i get that
the the the fact that they're trying to
enforce these rules are the joke
i look at this two different ways number
one who's actually gonna follow this ah
this birthday no no singing on my
birthday some people will
there are californians at will i i look
at this as not about who's going to
follow
that's not the point who's going to
follow it yeah i look at this as they
have to put something out
right like they can't just be blind to
the fact now
how are they going to enforce this are
the you know thanksgiving police going
to be knocking down your door like the
gestapo being like whoa
how many households we got here did i
see someone singing oh take that
stuffing out of your mouth put a mask on
i don't think they're gonna how
tell me how they're gonna enforce this i
don't think that's even
a possibility the way i look at it is
they're probably saying
we got to do something we got to say
something this is a super extreme i
agree
but they can't just be here's the fact
that be careful
be smart be careful but in you know
government legislative terms they it's
it's absurd no doubt
so however they need to say something uh
tucker carlson was on with adam kroll
and they said if the police show up just
say you're staging a rally and that's
perfectly fine
you're peacefully protesting in the
backyard
as if it's 20 degrees in new york on
thanksgiving you got to be outside
that's california what you just saw
right there is california they're
talking about california specifically
i'm going to give you
your guidelines right now and that was
just cal but that's all you think about
that's all you think about you you just
think about that's that's it no i gave
you two sides of the coin there that
it's absurd
but they have to say something let me
tell you what's what is
absurd if they enforce this
right now you just want to put a
guideline fine
if you enforce this and there's video
footage game over
you're going to see some crazy stuff
happen in california if they enforce it
i pray that they're bright enough
and have enough social intelligence
eq emotional intelligence to not go in
forces because if they do
right the amount of fire they're gonna
get from people from this
is gonna be absolute insane in the state
of california totally agree
here's what cuomo said my personal
advice is the best way to say i love you
this thanksgiving the best way to say
i'm thankful for you is to say
i love you so much i'm thankful for you
that i don't want to endanger you and i
won't i don't want to endanger
our family and i don't want to endanger
endanger our friends so we'll celebrate
virtually he added but this is my
personal opinion which is fine he can
have an opinion it's not a lot almost
because cuomo's speaking deck the guy
that decks people on the shelf listen
they're people on the shoulder that's
that guy if you travel
to one of the 41 states or territories
on new york's
travel advisory you will need to
quarantine for two weeks when you return
however the governor added you can go
where you want as the travel advisory is
not a
ban and their current guidelines that
they gave
10 people curfew 10 p.m curfew for all
bars restaurants gyms and liquor stores
10 p.m curfew curbside pickup or
delivery okay no alcohol to go
indoor and outdoor gatherings at private
residences
limited to 10 people so new york's given
a specific number it's 10 people
california is saying three households
including yours which they're really
saying 12 people yeah you got four times
three so that's new york what do you
think about it i think newsom is
seriously he has mental issues i mean
the level of detail that was on that
california list the new york list was a
little bit more practical
i mean it had some level of sanity built
into it
what's the point of i mean at least
their gyms are open at least gyms are
open in new york they're not even open
in california
at least they can stay at a gym until
ten o'clock or go to a bar till ten
o'clock we can't even do that in
california you talk about
uh uh enforcing the laws manhattan beach
there's every weekend the yellow
windbreakers are out on every street
corner in downtown if you don't have
your mask up over your nose
they've got clipboards they're they're
yelling at you they are moderately
enforcing now there's no way you can go
into people's homes
i mean there might be a stand your
ground situation if they try to do that
um but it just the the thing that really
kills me
is each week there's something new and
they keep talking about covet cases and
and all i can say is
i have a different mentality when it
comes to it i believe that we need to do
whatever we can to protect the people
that are most vulnerable
but everybody else just be smart and
have some common sense
my wife's entire family tested positive
for covid and they're all fine
they all were ready to go after a couple
two or three days they live in missouri
don't worry
um you know and then you hear about all
these athletes you know that test
positive in their back plane
in a week or less than that so the
hysteria has gotten so out of control
now they're using the holiday wait until
christmas rules come out
i mean agree this is absurd i don't
think there's any way that they can
enforce it i
totally agree that it's laughable it's
laughable it's laughable
but let's just look at some of the other
stuff that's out there i get it
uh 10 million covered cases we've just
crossed 10 million in the united states
these are facts
um really proud to say here in texas we
are
leading the way here baby one million
cases crossing texas we're number one if
you ain't first your last way to go
texas
um the the whole protecting people
um yes i think we can all agree young
healthy vibrant people are not the ones
that are
at risk but the concern is you show up
you want to give grandma a kiss
it's uh thanksgiving you start singing
boom grandma dies that's what people are
concerned about
yeah i mean that's a thanksgiving song
around my house you know this
point is it's not so much the young
people the kai ludis of the world
this crew over here but they show up
they come home for thanksgiving they see
their family
they give grandma a kiss now you're
going to grandma's funeral
that's the concern is that immediate
kiss death burial i mean move on yeah i
mean not immediate but i mean
are we we're going to play the game that
old people aren't dying yeah but we're
gonna play that game right now
no not playing that game at all but why
can't we determine
whether a grammar should come over
purchase or not why do we want to kill
your grandma
tom go ahead i'm just letting you know
that's the concern
like as much as i think that these rules
are a freaking joke and there's no way
to enforce them
and it is absurd and it's laughable
we're having a nice chuckle about it i
get it
covets real 10 million cases million in
texas where we are
and they're they need to have some sort
of guidelines by the way let me tell you
one thing let me tell you one thing
about when you say texas has the most
cases i
called ricky and i said ricky
go get your kova test you and your wife
no okay i call ricky
ricky says let me find one i said dude
let me just tell you where we go
there's one pretty much there's 15
places within a five mile radius here i
can go take the cove test
he calls and says pat there's none so
what are you talking about he says
there's none
i said ricky go find i'm getting upset
at this point i'd recommend ricky you
i'm thinking he's not being resourceful
he's just kind of doesn't want to go
take it
he says pam i'm telling you there is no
i said ricky find a place
there's gotta be one do you know ricky
and his wife had to drive
three hours to the closest place to get
cover tested
i believe it in california bakersfield
in california yes
i thought you mentioned but the point is
california hasn't made it as easy to
take tests as texas has
texas is made so easy you want to go get
bro over here every time
yesterday one of our guys their kids in
school something happened
one kid had a temperature 101 you know
what i'm talking about okay he had 101
degree temperature kid was at 103.5 this
morning he's doing better now
but they took her right off the bat to
get the kid tested you know how long of
a drive it was for her five minutes
one got tested negative came back home
california they don't have them
everywhere
so as much as people say texas is
leading the way
yeah texas has also made it accessible
not all
states have made it as accessible as
easy to go take the test
as texas has texas has no problem you're
going and taking the case
no question for you but they go out and
say oh cases cases yeah because texas
has done a phenomenal
nobody gives the credit to say great job
to texas
for making it very easy to go get tested
a lot of states are like i probably just
have a flu i don't need to go get tested
you may have had covet nobody knew about
it because you didn't go get tested
in texas you're going to know because at
least you have it available because a
state like texas wants to make it
available for you
but they get shafted every time they do
something like this and they get the
black eye
same thing nationally with the numbers
up if they're so
precautionary in california i mean you
live in california you got a lot of
people there you
obviously your whole family's there why
are they so measured
precautionary rules regulations and they
don't have testing
you know you're saying accessibility how
big is bakersfield can you go to
bakersfield
kai i think the popular function that
ricky lives in 50 i don't know the
bakersfield population what's
bakersfield population
bakersfield population right there
should come up
2020 390. kern county go kern county
kern county k-e-r-n county good luck
spelling that guy ker no he'll get this
current county there you go he's
improving a lot by the way 9 12.
912 000 that's the 11th largest county
in california almost a million people
and he had to go to glendale to get
covet tested what the hell are we
talking about so is that a function of
california
that is the governor is that a function
of current capital all of it is that i
put it all on california you got a
11th largest county you're making that
difficult for me to get tested
it's 275 a pop that the insurance pays
for right you just go and say i have the
symptoms you take it
insurance pays for the 275 you got
tested how do you not have it in a
county that's the 11th largest county in
california
how do you make it so difficult and the
places you go to guess what they say
we have covet testing but you don't get
the results for 14 days
14 days ridiculous you go to cvs oh we
do i did a covet testing for
cvs i did it twice yeah you know how
long it took for me to get my results 20
minutes cbs no no cvs
17 days oh wow i went to the local
you're a little off
by the way what do you call these places
what do you call these er places that
they have urgent care no you know which
ones i'm talking you see all over texas
plastic surgery plans no they have that
as well but the er place right here
three hours just wanna let you know
negative so every time i'm getting
tested because they want me to get
tested regularly you're negative you're
negative three hours
so why is there such a disparency in
three hours in certain places
you wanted three weeks in other places i
don't know i couldn't tell you i
i am not the governor of california i
have no desire to be the governor of
california but they can do things to
improve the testing
uh and they're not and governor abbey
gets a lot of credit no wonder nasdaq is
looking to move in their headquarters
over here great segue
because texas attracts businesses
musk is looking to come back here with
bigger projects you know rogan just
moved over here from
uh uh uh california and uh now you got
the
governor abbott shout out to governor
abbott low-key guy
you know he's not a big social media guy
he's not a big
uh person on social but he welcomes
stock exchanges to austin texas governor
abbott
will on november 200 host
representatives from the u.s major u.s
stock exchanges considering whether
whether they will relocate their data
centers from new jersey to the lone star
state
amid the threat of higher taxes love
these higher taxes you know what you
vote
andrew cuomo uh phil murphy uh de blasio
our friend corey booker good friend of
the show um
you know test me bro as as we said
before
you know it's they could make a power
move and and be in texas in no time i
mean you
did this yourself i mean you're a case
example right here yes california was
testing you testing you testing you and
you said you know what enough's enough
i got to move yep tom you know he just
announced that he's gonna be moving
california pretty soon
he's gonna make an announcement
hopefully he stays in the usa i know
there was a concern but i want you to
stay we all want you to stay tom
but at what point do you have to just
say [ __ ] it i'm out
i'm just gonna repeat what i say pretty
much every time on this podcast how are
we become so stupid as a country i mean
there are governors that are just
smarter that are just doing it better
desantis in florida your guy here in
abbot
in texas also keep in mind these two
states don't have state income taxes
and they still have a find a way to make
the state thrive and do well and attract
other businesses
i hope nasdaq moves i was shocked to
learn that new jersey
is the one capitalizing on all the tax
money on these transactions on wall
street are you kidding me did you know
that i mean you think of wall street you
think
you know new york city uh but new jersey
and
so it makes it makes total sense i hope
one of them because it's gonna break the
dam
if a big high-profile iconic brand
company institution something like
nasdaq were to actually move to texas
everybody would think it's okay and then
it's gonna then
you're gonna see some real issues for
these states like california
like new york and and especially with a
president
who is in lockstep with these governors
to just do whatever they can
to make your life miserable if you just
want to go about you know
trying to bring back the glory days of
2019 doesn't that seem like a long time
ago now
just to be clear these are the data
centers or data centers
not the actual exchanges so they they
could be anywhere for that matter it's
just
it's where they're housing yeah but but
you got to realize i mean
you are making it seem like it's not
really a big deal i'm not that's not
what i'm saying
that are paying a quarter of a percent
per financial transaction
averaging ten thousand a minimum of ten
thousand electronic trades each year so
this data center is the one that you
want to be over here
you want the data center definitely
you're not you're playing
that i'm just it's not like the the
nasdaq is physically no no no no no but
you're getting your stock exchange isn't
physically made exactly
where the cost is it's what's moving to
texas which is what abbott wants good
for abbot for doing that
i applaud him respect by the way if you
guys are following this right now
and watching this and you heard this
whole segment we went through california
against new york
california's guidelines are you can't
have more than three household
gatherings at the house
no singing no chanting uh you have to
wear a mask
in the outdoors you can't even have the
thanksgiving at your house you have to
be outdoor
and between bites and drinks you have to
put a mask on if you're not
how many of you that are watching this
if you were living in california or new
york
are going to follow the guidelines
if the answer is yes put thumbs down
right there push that thumbs down button
if you're saying hell no i would not
follow the guidelines
i'm still going to have a happy
thanksgiving i just may not invite my
grandmother to say stay home to be safe
press the subscribe button if there's no
way in the world you would entertain
any of these guidelines you're still
going to have it i'm actually curious
right now we're showing 23
thumbs down we're showing 30 200 subs
let's see what this goes to let's see
what people are going to say about this
go ahead i have a different question for
you because
obviously i think we can know where our
answers are going here and i'm on the
side of thumbs up for sure
you asked this question before i think
it's a good question to pose again
better state for entrepreneurs
better where would you rather be new
york or california you posed that
question at one point did you not
i did the results came in i think todd
did they not 50 50 yes they did
california for the weather if they were
that similar right they did they came
believe it or not i would take new york
over california you want me to tell you
why
exactly i tell you why because i don't
think to me it has nothing to do with
weather
of course i love the weather in
california of course my family is in
california
of course all of that stuff i think
people are starting to realize
how i'm wired it's very simple for me my
wiring my family took them a while to
understand this
i go where my values and principles are
protected the most
california my values and principles are
not protected
new york is more lenient than california
believe it or not
california on the taxes list is the 50th
worst
in america texas is 42nd for high
earners you're saying
period taxes period california's 50th
wars
new york is 40 second worse and you're
even seeing the way cuomo says it como
says what
here's my opinion this is what i think
you should do he's not enforcing
newsom is saying here's what we're gonna
do
it's a big difference in spirit garcetti
is demanding not a fan of de blasio at
all i think garcia and
the blast you're twins they're very very
similar one maybe seven four and the
other guy is 510 but they pretty much
are
twins but i think i think cuomo has a
little bit more appreciation for his
billionaires his entrepreneurs his job
creators than newsome does
i think cuomo understands business more
obviously by the way the hollywood
liberals in california that are
obviously very outspoken i mean these
are you know
these are your your peoples how do you
literally write down on paper that
take a bite of food and put your mask on
it it just it's
just it defies common sense it's just so
weird to think that you could be that's
that weird yeah you know to write that
down that's crazy so your vote is for
new york your vote you're staying in
california well i say they're both
completely in the toilet so i'll take
the better weather
yeah guys i'm going to take florida on
this one i'm just you catch me there at
south beach i'll be around there so
you gave me two options you fooled me
yeah i got you manipulated on you
you dirty shoulder moving forward right
thank you i'm gonna say this guy's about
to hit you in the shower that's it
you got it i'm gonna deck you put your
shoulder out there next time i'll attack
you
for some shots so let's look at some
stats here let's look at some stats here
let's look at some stats here
let's talk about voting okay i did a
video years ago and i want you guys to
watch this and and be
very transparent about what i think you
may say pat fully extreme
disagree all you want i won't be
offended by it i was 35 when i shot this
and i was fully
my mind hasn't changed much based on
that when you see it it's very extreme
i'm telling you it's very extreme but
you have to watch the whole thing for
you to be able to say i'm excited fine
but before we get into it before we get
into it i want to set this up let me
give you some of the ages that we have
in america and what you can do age
like what age you need to be to do
different things
you want to be a president how old do
you need to be 35 you want to be a vp
35 senator 30. congressman
25 we just had the youngest congressman
ever by the way
house of representatives i'm sorry 25 we
just had the youngest by the way just so
you know we broke the record
the youngest just won have you seen this
young kid good looking guy have you seen
this kid young kid
type it in youngest house of
representative
uh i think he's 28 maybe 27 type it in
he broke a record
uh no it's not a uh he beat aoc yeah he
beat it
it's a good looking uh uh uh 25 percent
what is north carolina
that's the one 25 years old uh uh right
there the dude in the wheelchair yes
they're doing a wheelchair
youngest 25 year old north carolina
representative republican madison
25 year old congratulations to in the
wheelchair
to uh uh what's his name i want to give
a proper shout out madison madison
cawthon hawthorne props to you
brother madison cawthorne if you know
him send him this message
uh this video here so 25 years old okay
sexual consent there you go watch this
what did you say
what was that first one sexual condition
okay got you let's go to sexual consent
this is the one
that fully flabbergasted everybody in
this room okay out of 50 states when you
think about
the right a to consent age to have sex
the
legal age to have sex what number do we
think about
i guess 16 18 something like that i
think about 18. i've never thought about
16. you guys think about 16
luis what do you think about 18. what do
you think about it
18 16. so you think about 16 two both of
you are under 16.
no no i want to retract that cut cut 18.
18. live buddy you're saying 16 now
because you saw the stats at the
beginning kai what do you think about it
in norway it's always been 16. norway's
always been 16. okay so check this out
if you didn't know now you're going to
know can you pull up the states
on what age you have to be to have legal
sex without getting rex arrested check
this out
she's almost done okay watch this watch
this go up a little bit
all of these states alabama's 16. so is
alaska arizona's 18. arkansas 16
california 18 colorado 17.
connecticut 60 meaning a 50 year old can
have sex with a 16 year old and you are
not gonna get
arrested whoa where are you getting the
50 year old thing
right there in what do you call it in um
closing close in age exception is that
exemption is that
exemption yes exemption colorado 17
connecticut 16 delaware 18
dc 16 dc all the politicians 16.
uh florida 18. good for you guys florida
does it right 18 georgia's 16 hawaii 16
idaho 18
illinois 17 indiana 16 iowa 16
kansas 16 kentucky 16 louisville are you
noticing
80 is 16 main 16 maryland 16
massachusetts michigan
minnesota 16 missouri 17 montana
nebraska nevada 16. new hampshire 16
jersey 16.
new mexico new york 17 carolina 16
dakota 18.
ohio oklahoma 16 oregon 18 i would think
oregon would have been like 15.
pennsylvania 16 rhode island
16. south carolina dakota 16 10 sc 18
good for them texas 17.
oh nice utah 18 vermont 16 virginia 18
washington 16
west virginia 16 wisconsin 18 wyoming
seven interesting here west virginia 16
but 15 if it's your sister so way to go
if it's your sister okay so so the legal
age to have sex
eighty percent of the states is 16. some
of the other ones is 18. okay
next criminal responsibility okay
criminal responsibility state by state
33 states set no minimum age of criminal
criminal responsibility for federal
crimes the minimum age of criminal
responsibility is 11.
driving 14 to 16 years old you can drive
with a permit
16 to 17 restricted license
18 unrestricted which by the way you
said it earlier today
can you are you comfortable with 16 year
olds driving a car i don't know i know
what i did the moment i passed my
driver's license i know exactly what i
did that minute
yeah when i got the car when i think of
how difficult it is to drive and
everything you have to know 16 is too
young
okay so that can be debated but it's 16
gambling 21
drinking 21 working 16-17
marriage 18 nebraska's 19 mississippi's
meaning in mississippi you can't be
married 21 years old yeah mississippi
nebraska's 19 we're learning stuff
retirement 62 to 67 leaving school
16 to 19 you can choose to leave i don't
want to go to school anymore mom i'm
dropping out
smoking they changed it eric was
devastated smoking
21 cigarettes and wheat is 21. you ready
voting is what 18. let me get this
straight
you mean to tell me i'm not allowed to
drink until i'm 21 years old
i am not allowed to smoke weed or
cigarettes till i'm 21 years old i'm not
allowed i'm not allowed to gamble
until i'm 21 years old but i'm allowed
to vote at 18. or you're allowed to die
for your country
and serve in the army or the military
it's absolutely pathetic to me
if you think about it it's absolutely
pathetic to me when you think about i
think the voting system
needs to be changed my opinion i've been
saying this for a long time okay
now i'm not a u.s i'm not a uh i wasn't
born here
i'm from iran i came over here
completely different perspective i have
but i shot this video six years ago six
to be exact the date if you pull it up
guys we can pull up the video date
it is april 15 2014 which is what
i look like i'm smoking weed right
[Laughter]
35 thanks kai for getting that picture
right there i'm wearing a babe ruth
jersey but let it do you have it on 1.5
speed by the way i don't know people are
voting
now we had 61.6 percent of eligible
voters show up
and in 2012 we had 58.2 percent show up
which has dropped
by roughly three percent and uh you know
the subject of voting keeps coming up
and i said we need to do an episode on
it and put some ideas together and i'll
put these ideas for a while but
i'll present it to you because look
we've had a lot of people that have
fought very hard whether it's to get
african-american civil rights to be able
to vote or women's rights we've come
along such a
long way but uh but i think we can even
improve it even more today than before
so let me get right into it let me get
right into it
the program i'm going to be talking to
you about is called earning the right
to vote earning the right to vote the
reason why it's called earning the right
to vote i'm an immigrant
i came here from iran to america america
was willing to open the doors and allow
our family to come here and iran we
didn't have freedom of religion freedom
of assembly freedom of speech freedom of
many many things free enterprise and so
in america they offered that to us but i
didn't come and feel and entitled to all
of it i felt as an immigrant i had to
give back and earn the freedom that
america gave me so the program is called
earning the right to vote first one
point number one if you paid a thousand
dollars in income taxes
the prior year you get one vote so what
if somebody pays ten thousand dollars in
income taxes you get ten votes what if
somebody pays a hundred thousand dollars
in income taxes you list 100 votes well
you may say pat that's not fair the
people who pay more taxes get more votes
i simply took the system on how public
corporations or companies who have
outstanding shareholders
and outstanding shares on the system
they used and this is how it works the
company could have
one million outstanding shares but only
a hundred people
own the 101 million outstanding shares
and the way they allow to vote is not
based on
the 100 shareholders if one person owns
only one share
versus a person owns a hundred thousand
shares which one has more to say more of
a voice for this company obviously a
person that has 100 000 shares and i
feel
our voting system should be the same
exactly
you ought to have more of a voice on
what [ __ ] is gonna get into somebody who
does not and if you want to have more of
a voice
you ought to pay a little bit more than
income taxes that's my idea on point
number one and there would be a salary
cap with 100 shares 100 votes you can't
go above 100 votes kind of like how
nfl has a salary account that's the way
we play at 100 votes and the age part
with this it has nothing to do with 18
years old 21 years old 25 years old 30
years old freaking
every 16 year old kid who worked at
baskin robbins last year and he made
fifteen thousand dollars and he paid two
thousand dollars in income taxes he
ought to have two
votes yes you do
i would rather hear from the 16 year old
kid who's paying income taxes and
contributing to society than a 23 year
old kid that is undecided wants to stay
home family pays for all his bills he
doesn't want to give back to society i'd
rather hear from the 16 year old
point number two of the ideas haven't
played if you serve the military whether
you pay any taxes or not
you get a vote uh but you need to
complete boot camp and ait advanced
individual training i think military is
a good thing for a lot of our younger
boys to go into because it disciplines
them teaches us a lot about
independence toughness fight freedom
honor a lot of good things i think it'll
do a lot of good things for the country
period but if somebody in the military
paid fifteen thousand dollars in taxes
he would get 15 votes because his
numbers would still
go higher but if somebody went to the
military and didn't pay any taxes you're
still getting one vote because you serve
the military
point number three public service police
officers
similar to military if you're willing to
put your life on the line and go fight
fires while your wife is at home
wondering what's going to happen you got
two little ones
you want to put your life on the line
for me i mean you you have more than
earned the right to vote same with
police officers and so you get an
additional vote if you are serving for
public service
and putting your life on the line you
absolutely get the right to vote as well
uh
because of what you're doing number four
job creators nonprofit or profit
if you create a job that pays a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars
over a four-year period income so if you
hired somebody and they make forty
thousand dollars a year and they're with
you for three years you paid 120 000
you get one vote per job you created for
our economy
one vote per job you created for the
economy and the limit on that is also
100 votes you created 100 jobs you have
100 votes to uh to vote for any kind of
things that we're coming out with point
number five
retirement sales that's paid over ten
thousand dollars in life taxes they
automatically get to vote because
they've already put into economy they're
put into the
uh to the marketplace they put into our
country to contribute to society so they
get a vote no matter what the number is
ten thousand dollars
number six anyone with a four-year
degree whether you have paid into taxes
or not if you're willing to stay
disciplined
go to school get educated you ought to
get a vote and for a master's degree two
votes and for phd three votes so if you
have a bachelor's
if you have a master's and you have phd
you ought to be able to have three votes
because you have this supporting that
you've gone out and finished education
more than some of the rest of us and we
want to hear from you more because you
want to put your head down and read the
books and educate yourself i think we
need more people to go out and educate
themselves like the people who stay
disciplined to get their four-year
degree
degree in their phds and obviously this
whole thing would be uh needing to have
an id to go out there and vote but we
know more time
seven years this is how it'll look like
if somebody made 60 thousand dollars
last year they pay 1 000
in taxes that's 10 votes if that person
also has a bachelor's degree and a
master's degree they get two additional
votes if they
served in a military before that's an
additional vote that person could have
realistically 13 votes
uh to vote for an election because of
how much they've contributed to society
but this is the disclaimer idea what it
has to do with legal immigrants because
we have this whole debate with amnesty
and i've been interviewed on this one
you're about to like
this so many times people say oh they
ran across the border and we need to do
this and we need to do that honestly
if i'm a father and if i'm living in a
country where i see it's not the best
thing for my kids or if i see what's
taking place in iran or mexico or any of
that stuff and i gotta prove
i'm responsible for my kid i would go
across the border to come to america to
provide a better life for my kids
wouldn't you think about that i would
too but if you look at immigration the
whole purpose of immigration is to bring
the best talent in the world to our
country we are leading immigration
because
the best talent from china from europe
from everywhere they are still wanting
to come to america it's not as ahead of
a lead as we used to have at one point
right now to drop a little bit but we
bring the best talent so we have
11.7 million illegal immigrants living
in america roughly 400 000 of them were
deported last year
and out of that 11.7 million of illegal
immigrants they paid a little shy of 11
billion dollars in taxes last year so
what do we do with the folks who are
illegal immigrant living in america this
is my opinion these are my ideas i think
if one is illegal immigrants but they
did any one of these things we talked
about
if they went out there and they actually
paid a thousand dollars in income taxes
on the tax id number if they went out
there and actually
served the military are willing to serve
the military if they're willing to go
out and save the military they're
willing to become cops police officers
they're qualified
they're willing to go out and create
jobs they're willing to go out there and
get a degree and get educated if they're
willing to do these things
i say we need to allow and give them the
right to go out there and
and take a quiz because they need to
take a test to know the history of
america with a president and certain
things that they need to know about
but i think their votes ought to count
as well uh for what they do to society
to play a very very important role
there's no reason why we should not have
illegal immigrants uh being able to vote
as well there are more people that are
illegal immigrants that are contributing
more to society than somebody would
surprise you a little bit in society
why not let them be heard as well if
they're willing to earn the right to
vote by contributing to society so what
we did is
we went to the streets and we went on a
couple of college campuses you don't
need to listen to all of them but watch
the first the second guy will shot
somebody subjects such as voting in
politics and here's some of the answers
we got
all right so first question is how would
you improve the current voting system in
the united states
um i was going to say maybe more parties
but it'll probably complicate things
it'll take too long probably for things
what i would do is make the vote that
the people put uh when they go to the
booth and vote make that the one that
counts not the one that takes place
behind closed doors when it goes back to
the offices
in the end it's just popular really
matters shout out to mario doing the
interviews by the way different areas
encourage more people to vote i would
make it more convenient for people to
vote by decreasing the super pacs
probably better informed people by the
way he went to ucla like people like me
don't really want to they're too lazy
don't know how to even though it's
really easy prefer for there to be um
better access to voting booths as far as
politically you know you got the
republicans the the democrats
um you can pause it i think that's why
you can pause it at this point okay
by the way i hope you don't get flagged
for use in the video of valuetainment
from six and a half years ago these guys
aren't going to come after us
so tell me about this guy stomp the
level of detail is staggering
staggering here's my first thought we
have poll workers who can't count to one
how are they going to count to 33 no but
there's some great points in there
um it clearly uh shows that
we just witnessed it you know things are
messed up you know i think there has to
be some sort of changes
when tick tock can you know help decide
elections
and influence people to the level that
they do and these kids are armed with
votes
and maybe not armed with the knowledge
that they might need
something is a skew and the only way
anything would ever happen
is um the party in power found a way
that it benefited them
then they would then you know make it
happen but
how long did it take you to come up with
that formula were you working on it for
a long time oh yeah
oh yeah i've been by the way i've been
talking about that since i was 30 years
old
but i've never put in video i've been
talking if you work closely with me they
tell you
pat's crazy ideas that that i propose to
our guys for a long time i think
every single thing about a company like
to say i don't like something starbucks
does
who the hell am i to tell starbucks what
to do if i don't share the company
if i own more shares i should have more
say if i don't i shouldn't
what's the difference between that and
america but in america it's like
no even the person that doesn't own
shares of
starbucks who doesn't contribute or do
anything should have say no they
shouldn't you shouldn't have any saying
it
in a household if you're not paying rent
for the house
i'm living in you got three roommates
adam you've ever had roommates
yes if you got three roommates you ever
had a roommate that never paid the bill
or never paid anything living with you
yeah a little bit
do they have any say in how for you to
bring in groceries at the table are they
paying the utilities they bring
the hell they still living with you if
they're not will you let them say
anything about how you should shift the
way you put set up your house or
apartment
good good analogy you would never let
anybody tell you what to do who the hell
are you to say anything
all i'm saying is let's pay some taxes
why don't you go pay some taxes get in
the game that's all it is
have some skin in the game go pay your
taxes and then say what makes total
sense what about all good for me what
about a mandatory age for you where are
you at as far as voting
i could care less about age i really
could care less about age because
to me it's not about age i know 16 year
old kids i'm being dead serious with i
know 16 year old kids more responsible
than 30 year old kids
this kid came over here from colombia
sam came here from columbia at 14 years
old
his father his father passed away he
comes to colombia
independent who's paid your bills the
last seven years who has paid your bills
last seven years
that guy should have had a vote since he
was 15 years old if he paid him to tell
him well according to your plan you'd
have 12.
what i'm trying to say to you is i don't
care about age i care about you
paying taxes the pain of paying taxes
you ought to have a voice democrat
republican independent i could care less
but now you have skin in the game it's
not anything well based on taxes is what
you're saying this
i didn't just say taxes you didn't see
taxes okay that's education if you get a
degree you have military if you serve
the military you have votes if you want
to be a firefighter you have votes
it's skin in the game dude firefighters
we sit there we see firefighters with
things just a regular
i one time got into a market i remember
this kevin pearson guy years ago if he
hears this he's going to be shell shock
i remember his name because i was like
17 years ago
and i went through the market of
firefighters for a span of six months i
worked with these firefighters and it
was a bunch of these guys all studs
you know how many of them went through a
divorce every one of them had a divorce
it's a rough life
it's tough for personal life it's tough
for parenting they go through challenges
they lose friends they're burned legs
body parts
coming home these are not easy jobs
everything we're talking about bashing
cops
you go talk to a wife and a son who lost
their dad on a
you know front line doing work they got
shot they got then then go ask him what
it feels like to be a cop you think that
kid wishes his dad wasn't a cop that kid
wishes that had a regular job working at
staples or a different place these
people deserve the right to have so for
me it's not about just taxes
it's about earning the right to vote so
you can have say
if you're looting if you're going out
there fooling around ruin what this
great nation is all about you should
have
zero say zero vote nothing
if you're not contributing to the
society zero i'm in
i mean the level of time and effort that
you did to even come up with this
completely wild and outlandish plan is
actually incredible it gives us
some deep insight into your mind i mean
obviously
it's very complicated and we don't know
how many votes certain person would get
is complicated i mean is it fair to say
that
that's not getting implemented anytime
soon however
i i do with
amazing level of respect
the fact that you care that much to take
the because that wasn't easy to come up
with i mean how much man hours it took
you to come up with that
that's that's what we need more of
people who care that much saying this is
what it needs to be
i'm not even talking about left right
you know center
i'm just talking about you care that
much this is what it means to be an
immigrant from
iran to do you have no voice there when
you can earn your voice go to the army
become a businessman become an
entrepreneur
you know one thing that i'm happy to see
i mean to
to that yeah we just had the highest
voter turnout since
1900 in america so whatever you want to
say about
we would not have had the highest
turnout since 1900
if we had to check everyone's id there's
no way in the world this would have been
the highest
you realize no way in the world this
would have been the highest if we all
had to see the id
zero chance that's what you think it
came down to no no no no i don't think
that's what it came down to
it's absolute math it's not maybe
it's not 99 accurate statement i'm
making this is
100 statement i'm making if we had to
check
100 of everyone's ids who voted we
wouldn't have this many votes
so how do you vote without id mail and
balance what do you mean that's just how
you don't have to have an idea no you
just dropped what do you mean you just
drop how'd you do it
i mean that had my name on the ballot
yeah but did you show your id or no i
had a mail in ballot no but so you
didn't show it so how did they know you
sent it and nobody knows somebody else
could have
said they're saying have to show up
there is no way in the world
listen a decision this big a decision
you know what this would do this system
look a lot of people are saying
i'm conservative i absolutely disagree
with pat i love that
some people are saying screw the
snowflakes fine
some people are saying i'm a
conservative i partially agree with some
of them
some people are saying i 100 agree with
pat the whole point is
i don't care whether you agree or not
start the damn conversation
i don't care if you agree and you want
to break the whole thing down go do it
start the conversation there's no way
and by the way adam for yourself you
know a lot of people
would see a program like this and you
know what they would say they would say
it's so extreme
but you know what's crazy that's exactly
how they live their lives
let me say this one more time a lot of
people would see this thing here and say
it's extreme
but that is exactly how they raise their
kids
that's exactly how they live their lives
you and i just talked about somebody in
your life where you said you know they
had their kids
ever again that'll be the last time if i
get a feeling
that you're just thinking because i have
money and you want me to pay every time
we're done it's not going to happen
again we'll hang out you ain't going out
with me again because i know you're
thinking
i should take the bill because i have
money i don't play that game because
everybody ought to have
a skin in the game this is not a radical
idea
people live this life voting-wise scares
the [ __ ] out of them in case if we go in
this direction which that part i
understand because a lot of people will
lose their votes yeah and the people who
that
conceivably could be in power here very
very shortly this is the last thing
they'd want
because this worked out very well for
them how it just happened
and to think that we're not even
seriously considering uh changing
you know how this voting is going um so
how many votes would you would you have
in in the pbd
voter system how many votes would you
have i don't care to have a
record-breaking vote or two i'm not
asking
you know how many people like which
votes would you have personally no he's
saying in your formula
i don't know uh yeah i have no idea how
many
i'd be limited at 100 because i'd reach
my limit i wouldn't have more than 100
votes listen if i pay 50 million dollars
in taxes i'm not getting 50 million
votes i'm only getting 100 votes
so there's a cap at 100. there's no
abuse so a billionaire cannot say i got
17 million votes no you don't you only
have 100 100 votes
but i would want you to max out your
votes go get 200 votes
i would encourage you to go get your 100
votes go become a hundred vote person
so you can say my vote is a hundred
votes
have pride in it i'm a hundred vote
person i voted then people would say
damn they'd have to print a lobby i
would recognize you in america
i would say wear the shirt that says i
had a hundred votes people gonna say
that's that guy's a hundred club damn
adam's part of the hunter club legit
dog good for you now the person says ten
votes good for you bro ten votes
now four votes how do you have four
votes i got my phd phenomena and i got
this okay phenomenal man congratulations
to you it becomes a real recognition how
many
i just voted why do you think the vote
doesn't matter to them because you
didn't earn the right to vote you just
got voted because you hated somebody
yeah it's not how voting should be
voting should be great freaking job
and good for you and if people um take
some pride in voting they could also
lose the right right didn't you say by
rioting and things like that you could
lose votes
yeah interesting
amazing thought formula here uh by the
way if you're watching this
if you're watching this and you guys are
saying it's lagging youtube had problems
yesterday lagging they do today as well
they had issues our t1 line is solid
right and everything is solid on our
side right now youtube had
a lot of issues yesterday you can go on
twitter and see their account on what
they said they're doing the same thing
again today
but those of you guys that are still
with us uh great if you missed any part
of it we'll repost this as well short
clip for you to see we have the
recording right so we can post a
recording for them to see without any of
the
glitches all that stuff okay thank you
for your patience but watch this
i'm curious if you listen to what i
pitched right now with ideas
and you agreed with eighty percent of
what i had to say
push the thumbs up button if you didn't
put the thumbs down button
if you have opinions that you want to
share with me personally
send me an email i want to hear from you
actually send me an email
specific and let me know what's going on
with some of the ideas i said
because again going back to it to me you
don't trust me to
drink until i'm 21. you don't trust me
to smoke wheat or cigarettes until i'm
21. you don't trust me to
gamble until i'm 21 but you trust me to
vote at 18
having never paid any taxes and i have
the right to vote
problematic we shouldn't celebrate that
record-breaking people turn out to vote
that's no celebration we should
celebrate
a record-breaking amount of people pay
taxes we should celebrate a
record-breaking amount of people
created a job we should celebrate a
serve the military we should celebrate a
record-breaking amount of people
winning got bachelor's degree we should
celebrate the record-breaking amount of
people that became cops and firefighters
we should celebrate service service
service
service service that's what we should
celebrate
the more we celebrate that guess how
everybody thinks at that point
service when the basic thing about how
you teach dogs is what
dog poop pees outside what do you do you
give him a treat
good job buddy awesome job come here
here's a treat phenomenal job
dog goes and does everything you ask him
to do you give him a treat
when we become kids what do parents do
with us good job buddy you did your
chores
great job you can watch some tv you can
play some video games right whatever we
incentivize
kids adults in america they're going to
do that the rest of their lives
if you incentivize me sitting home and
collecting checks i'm going to be doing
that
if you want me to just stay home and in
california going to put me at a
four-star hotel
you said wow four-star hotel really
why would i want to be homeless you're
incentivizing that
it's pathetic that this is even have to
be explained the concept that this has
to be explained
is what's really pathetic about it yeah
the idea that this is somehow a
controversial concept is what's pathetic
about it
if we got a country give us 10 million
people
give us a country the size of i don't
know give us a land the size of texas
give us a country the size of florida
give us 20 years
look what happened to our country let me
say this one more time if we had a
country
where we set up the guidelines our
constitution our values and principles
based on the way we want to do it
give us 20 years and see what would
happen we beat a hub of innovation
around the world
we beat a hub of the best talents around
the world we would create and solve
every problem in the world if we had the
right values and principles that we
could create
not this nonsense stuff to try to please
everybody yeah and
we're just at the beginning of a
four-year cycle of it it's uh kind of
sad
let me ask you pat yeah again kudos
shout out to the even your your train of
thought here
but we talked about 16 and 18 year olds
yep you know drinking smoking uh voting
driving all that
you know i would say 90
plus percent of high school students 16
18 are just in school they're not
working they're not
working at baskin robbins the majority
right i mean obviously some kids are
working and doing like little part-time
jobs
not paying much in taxes is my point
fair point sure
okay the the the question i have
is doesn't that sort of disincentivize
them
meaning they have not paid any taxes
they're 18 years old so the next time
that they'd be able to vote
is at age 22. so now you have a you know
a
six year span four to six year span of
our youngest minds our high school
students are college students i'm not
talking about whether they're liberal
conservative
yeah that's you know five plus years of
them being completely disengaged in
politics yeah
isn't that sort of no you know what it
does what is that here's what it does
it makes it that much more special when
you get the right to vote you celebrate
that much more when it's not a handout
you celebrate the vote a father takes a
son and saying i'm so proud of my son he
earned the vote
a mother takes her daughter and her son
saying i'm so proud of my kids they
earned the right to vote today and it's
emotional
parents cry kids will cry i earned this
vote
versus here's who i'm going to vote for
because somebody in school hates
such and such i'm going to vote for the
other guy that's what i'm going to vote
for you think they vote
logically do you think 18 years are
going to vote logically you really think
18 year olds world lodge no but
okay again i love your idea here but
here's another problem
yeah you're 18 you still haven't paid
anything in taxes yeah you go
go to college okay you're taking out
student loan debt you i mean your
daughter just graduated from
from college right pepperdine she i
assume she has not had a job per se
so you go to college you're there for
four years you still have not paid any
taxes you've taken on debt
now you're 22. well you know what [ __ ]
it i want to get my masters i want to go
get my doctorate get it
now you're going to school for another
two more two years four years
so now you have a lot of 25 year olds
who have still
never voted didn't you get it that a
bachelor's degree gets a vote
yeah but until you're 25 know you know
his degree takes 22.
what are you talking about so when
you're 22 you get one vote
of course i don't care if you've ever
been there's millions and millions and
millions of people that
don't get to vote until they're age 25
but if they don't they're
i was paying taxes at 16 years old
what age did you pay taxes first time
you ever pay taxes yeah
probably 18. i don't know okay yeah you
earned your vote
you had a thousand dollars in taxes
that's it okay you earned
your vote i'm proud of you you earned
your vote we ought to be proud
of our 16 17 18 year old kids who earned
we ought to celebrate
people earning their vote let me say
this it's a
celebration it's a recognition it's a
milestone a man a woman should have on
the wall
in my lifetime i've had 13 000 votes in
my lifetime i've had
628 votes it's a celebration okay
last year i had 62 votes you're a
shareholder i own a piece of america
i'm proud to be american i love this
country i have skin in the game
i'm with you dude the reason that i have
so many questions on this isn't because
i'm like well i think this no i know i
know you're not
because it's such a fascinating idea
it's such a fascinating school of
thought
such a fascinating way that i even think
about it that i'm asking these questions
because i'm thinking hmm
well what about this what about that
what because it's it's it's it's it's
sparking some things that are so takara
truth says yeah let's ruin democracy
path great go more
go deeper into it tell me what you mean
by that voting should be based on
meritocracy
16 here as well raul castillo raul
calido are you paying taxes i pay taxes
at 13 years old
had a work permit to work as a miner
patrick healer i have
no problem with the age paying taxes
i could care less about the age i care
about the habits so can you vote at age
13.
i pay taxes adam could you vote at age
13 i could
because a 13 year will understand the
pain of paying taxes
i wouldn't care if a 13 year old voted
they paid into the system
if you're 12 years old you own a share
of a company i don't care if you own a
share of the company you have say
what do you want to vote for you have
say to me you know how they say the
brain is not fully functioning until
you're 25 years old you've heard this
saying before
yeah some of them say it happens at 30
some say it's 25 years old that's why
even a rogan says he doesn't believe kit
should smell he says you shouldn't smoke
weed until after 30.
what a point don't smoke we don't tell
you 30 years ago
so ridiculous but it's not about so
ridiculous what he's trying to say is he
didn't start smoking weed until later on
in life he was not a smoker early on
he started later on so it's a lot he's
gone down a dirty path it's a
logical processing to say brain be
informed
but if you're 14 years old and you've
already experienced what it's like
to pay taxes you've had the pain of
being independent listen i trust you
more than a 25 year old
that's got a silver spoon in his mouth
never had a job it's a schlep sleeping
on everyone friend's couch and [ __ ]
and complains about mommy and daddy
and the fact that he wants another
thousand dollars from his rich dad yeah
that guy shouldn't have a say where does
this factor into bloated government and
big government because this ain't an
easy system there's gonna have to be
the most ridiculous in-depth system to
count the votes you did paid this taxes
and you got your doctor and you get 13
votes
but then you failed a class and the next
thing you know you got to you know go
back to school and then you only get 14
vote like
it could get it's a slippery slope here
again i commend the thought process here
it's ridiculous it's absurd to see your
brain
in action it's just there's a lot johnny
johnny just paid five bucks he says
by the way some of you guys paid 20
bucks 15 bucks 10 bucks i saw it i'm
trying to catch up to you pbd's on the
roll i'm 100 and tell me
where your new test country is eric
whittlemeyer
uh man i want to recognize the other
guys we didn't catch you but uh we will
next time love the idea of
uh johnny van johnson but voter fraud
would be even worse if votes weren't
correlated to population one-on-one i
don't think so i disagree i think it'd
be a lot easier to do that because it's
data
it's data if you have the data to show
you
work you have it if i can show my tax
here's how much i paid it
irs would know how much i paid in taxes
it's data it's automatic data
all of that it's trackable see it's easy
to track who's a shareholder that's not
hard to do
it's easy to track who's giving their
opinions on a shareholder call because
you know who it's a document that
everybody has who's a shareholder
at the end of the year the government
could print out a system to say this
year
this is how many votes you get adam who
do you want to vote for yeah and there's
people that just say you know what i got
100 votes i've qualified but i'm not
going to vote
that's okay don't you think there's
people's there's just two different
types of people in this country people
that want to be in
feel they should be incentivized to do
things that you've earned the right to
do something like vote
and everything else and everybody else
that thinks that hey it's my privilege
it's my right i can do whatever i want i
can do that look at
look at california they spend way more
time trying to figure out what you can
do in between bites of a thanksgiving
dinner
than something practical like this and
there's no way
that there's any the sad thing is
there's no way for any hope for this
because
the democrats would never want something
like this how do you count dead people
then
you know let's get all the the kids
coming in there to vote that don't even
know what they're doing
yeah no this this the chance just so you
guys know i'm not pitching this to see
that this is going to be past the next
couple years the chances of this passing
the chances of this passing is more
likely in a different country than in
america
the chances of discussions they would
call you a racist for even coming up
with the idea i'd love it i would love
to debate anybody who calls me racist
i'd love i'd have such a fun time with
them if they called me racist what
country could you see this happening
any country that wants to compete with
america because america is getting so
soft that
look here's how competition works let me
tell you how competition works
competition works the moment you notice
a nation getting arrogant
be ready the moment a nation gets
arrogant be ready
be ready it's interesting times coming
around the corner the moment you get
arrogant cocky in sports
in business what do arrogant people do
they no longer wake up at the same time
they no longer have the same fire the
urge
you know i'm interviewing a guy
yesterday he says uh oh
what's gonna make you more fired up
today because you have more money today
than before
how is that fire still gonna be i said
you don't know who i am i'm more fired
up today than i've ever been in my life
and you guys both know what i'm talking
about our body here
i said i have more fire in my belly
today than i've ever had enough 42
i'm more fired up today than i was at 23
years old then i was 25 years old i'm so
fired up so it's
you got 100 votes now you know you get
the time i've had 100 votes since i was
26 years old about 100 votes for a long
time
900 votes is not a recent thing you said
you look like a million dollars what i
tell you
i've looked like a million dollars since
i was 27 28. this is not about
looking like it this is about knowing
and thinking like it this is
logical reasoning you don't have to
agree with it i'm not telling you this
is going to pass
i'm not telling you you know the chance
i can't even run for office i can't run
for president i can't run for it i'm not
born here
but all i'm saying is if a country took
this idea and their
foundation from the beginning is like
this that's a dangerous country
everybody would wake up saying i can't
wait to earn my vote
and i wish you had the choice to go to a
country like that yeah
i wish there was something felons get a
chance to vote in your country
you're paying taxes yeah yes you do
you're a felon yes you do you know why
can a felon own a share of apple yeah of
course of course i don't care if you're
a felon
you get to vote because there's your
skin in the game yeah
i don't care about felons i don't care
about to me it's skin
in the game you pay taxes
you're a felon totally understand you
screwed up hey
bad for you should have never done that
but you came out you got a job you paid
three thousand dollars in taxes you have
a vote
100 color doesn't matter discrimination
doesn't matter i don't care what color
you are what nationality or what
religion you are i could care
less that's your choice atheists
agnostic christian seven day
catholic doesn't matter height
any of that stuff doesn't matter do your
thing you contribute you get to vote
okay paul nieto the third
i like it it goes in a way of what
socrates said
and more with not only a knowledgeable
voter but service or helping community
as well now we have people voting
because cardi b said to vote for biden
that's pathetic
and it's true it's 100 true he's right
yeah
so so and it would like you know that's
that lap vote check this out
let's let's let's go into the
conversation i was having with you guys
yesterday about the guy that i talked to
uh
yeah so so so i was telling you i was
talking to peter schweitzer yesterday
and if you guys don't know who peter
schweitzer's kai you want to pull up on
google who peter schweitzer is
uh peter schweitzer is uh uh
there you go peter schweitzer he is the
former uh william j casey research
fellow
at stanford university hoover
institution okay peter schweitz he's
written a lot of books go to amazon so
we can show the books
he's written a lot of they're just
typing right there amazon the bottom
right their third one is
him there you can do that as well so
he's written a lot of books now
obviously it's one-sided he wrote
clinton cash which affected the last
election
okay and that book got i don't know how
many thousands of views
reviews that affected clinton because
everybody talked about
clinton cash profiles in corruption he
breaks down
everybody left right middle everybody
mcconnell family everybody
uh and the recent one is secret empires
i asked him a question yesterday i think
we were having this conversation i said
i want to bring it up today
the question was who are the most
powerful
organizations or individuals in america
today and before you guys answer it i
actually want to hear from you as well
that you're watching this and i want you
to rank this so hear me out when i'm
saying this
because i want to hear you rank these in
the comment section okay so
adam if you're ready hi i want to hear
from you as well
uh uh uh you were in it so you can't
play along luis i want you to think
about the answers here as well eric
youtube i've forgotten if that matters
yeah
i'll tell you right now you told me i
asked him a question i said who are the
most powerful people in america today
i said number one the president
of the united states okay i just said
not in a list i'm just saying yeah this
is one is present united states yeah
second one is billionaires third is
universities fourth is
social media companies fifth is
mainstream media
who's the most powerful let me read it
again presidents
billionaires universities social media
companies
or mainstream media once again
presidents
billionaires social media companies
universities
or mainstream media from first
to last who do you say is the most
powerful to the least powerful his
answer was shocking and i agree with him
first or less who would you say i'm
going to step out because i know the
answer because
in the media but i'll have some comments
later okay you go ahead who's from the
most powerful to the least powerful
most i have just
off the top of my head here most
powerful right now in america
are social media companies okay so
social media for you is the top
i would put number two media um
for some reason i i feel like the
president according to this list would
be
last although i i would disagree with
that
um i got billionaires in universities
coming in at three and four and
you got billionaires third you got
billionaires third university
university's third okay university third
fourth
and then president last yeah
okay president's last what do you say
luis who's the most powerful eric who's
the most powerful so i'm
i'm kind of going that way but i'm going
to flip the one and two
let's do media mainstream media first
then social media
okay all right cool i like that eric
what do you say i think it's social
media then it's
uh media then it's universities then
it's billionaires and then there's the
president so you guys are identical
the two of you are identical kai who do
you have and he's a conservative
uh i say universities or social media
first
then universities then media then
billionaires then the president
hang on so social media first then
universities
mainstream media then mainstream media
uh
billionaires and then president okay so
here's what he said okay here's what he
said
and we got a lot of different people
here you know energized with andres
royal family
ryan lynn says msm social bureaus
college presidents that's it so msm's
first then social media companies then
billionaires then college
universities and presidents for ryan
lynn uh juan guzman put social media and
billionaires are the same thing to him
okay ron harris is illuminati great we
went to a completely different direction
there but okay i'm going to give you a
shout out all right so here we go here's
what he said
number one at the top social media
companies okay
most powerful yeah most powerful zuck is
the most powerful non-alice in the
world the world not just not elected if
he's the most powerful in the world wow
zuck is the most powerful if he ran for
office
he dictates everything he is demo so he
said socialist first
he said universities are second
he said presidents congress third
is what he put fourth he put uh
mainstream media
fifth he put billionaires he says
billionaires are irrelevant today
he says no one cares if you're a
billionaire there's so many of them
billionaires don't matter
they used to thirty years ago but they
don't do today there's a lot of
billionaires if i read the forbes
or fourth 2004 you wouldn't know 80 of
the names if i read the names to you
okay so social universities
president msm then billionaires thoughts
number one
what a scary list it's completely
horrifying and i'll tell you why
because you look at number one and
number two and you could put media at
number three mainstream
if you wanted to three of the five 60
percent
don't entertain other thoughts than
their own
they they will shut you down if you have
a conflicting opinion than them on
social media and don't think they don't
know their power
either they know exactly how powerful
they are they just showed it
um and the other thing universities as
number two if that's what he says that's
scary too because they're not
allowing any other thought in liberal
arts universities you are not allowed
to have a conflicting opinion of him and
if you look at the numbers of people
that
um professors in college it's like 35 to
one
when it comes to a conservative versus a
liberal 13-1 13-1 washington
okay and not only that but they're
they're militant they they won't just
hey i disagree with you i respect your
thought or something like that
they they will shut you down they they
will attack you
so to me this is a very very frightening
thing and they're only getting more
powerful yeah
adam yeah i think we all
agreed that social media was number one
especially these days i mean we're
seeing
you know in congress just last week who
had to show up
zuck jack dorsey looking like zz tops um
how do we say the ceo of google's name
how do we say his name anyone anyone
anyone
sundar pinchai thank you for that kai uh
our
22 year old who's able to vote these
days uh social media number one i think
you know that's a scary situation
university's number two why are
universities number two you think
because they're training the next crop
of people that are coming out to
what they believe what percentage of
americans go to university 25
the ones that are the cultural elites
that end up on the coast that dictate
everything that's going on in this
country forgot a point it's the people
that end up
i mean think about it right now the
ticket to getting a nice job is through
what a degree
so if you get a nice special beginning
it is changing but it's been like this
for a while
universities as of right now has extreme
influence are we saying that it's the
universities or the products of the
universities meaning like you go to
harvard you become
a you know no it's the universities what
they're training you the the culture
i'm sure that's what i mean it's a
cultural thing with professors what
they're doing you're saying it's the
teachers
the professors yes i mean where are you
going it's not well
what is the university is the professor
like you know you are going to be taught
by a professor on whatever he or she
thinks
well these days so online it's hard to
get influenced as much
and then what president was number three
the president was numbered where was
number three
where was president you know 50 years
ago for probably first place number one
right
and he lumped congress into that number
yeah he said congress he specifically
said congress i'm president well thank
god that you know the president doesn't
have
ultimate say you know congress but the
point is the point is the president
is no longer the most powerful man on
the planet it's no longer that's no
longer the case
guys twitter is censoring the president
think about what i just said right there
twitter censors the president twitter
dictates what the president can say
and not say who has the power president
president can't tell twitter hey
show what i have to say that that is uh
you right there
you realize who really has the power
ain't no president and to even document
that more
when the president can actually showcase
the power he has
it's through social media i mean that's
where trump has his most power
when he's communicating to his base
through social media which even
further illustrates how powerful it is
people are saying audio is lagging like
crazy what's what's the story they're
saying audio is lagging like crazy
is it matching with the video or no is
it is it is a little bit of lag that's
what they're saying but anyways okay
let's continue so
interesting take hi can you pull up what
biden's camp is saying they're going to
do
when they become uh president with covet
19 i don't know if you got that article
or not this is pretty interesting
because
this is what they're considering doing
the moment biden takes office
their recommendation is i don't know if
you have it i emailed it to you i
emailed it to you to kind
valuetainment.com
it is something i sent you kai i don't
know if you're seeing it or no
i have it right here if i can send this
to you
it's on daily wire or cnbc if you go to
cnbc
type in biden covet advisor says
biden covet advisor says covet advisor
says yeah there you go go to that
right there first one good biden coveted
advisor says u.s
lockdown of four to six we could control
pandemic and revive the economy
okay go a little higher let's read this
dr michael
ostrohome which by the way if you guys
don't know who he is he
was the first guy that came out on joe
rogan he got like 20 million views
coronavirus advisor to president-elect
joe biden said a nationwide lockdown
would help
bring the virus under control in the u.s
he said the government could borrow
enough money to pay for package that
would never
cover lost income for individuals and
government during a shutdown we could
really watch
ourselves cruising into the vaccine
availability in the first and second
quarter of next year while bringing back
the economy
long before that go a little higher to
see if there's anything else below
go a little higher uh to see if we don't
know we're going to provide something
okay so four to six weeks what do you
think four to six week adam shutting it
down
four to six weeks i mean obviously we're
not we're trying to avoid another
shutdown that's something
that but that's what they're saying to
do right yeah well i mean sometimes
i'm gonna play devil's advocate here the
covet is back
we've been saying that it's not been
gone no meaning it it was
it was going down over the summer boom
they've been saying it that once the
fall and the cooler weather happens
kobet's back i mean trump's been saying
we're rounding the curve around in the
curve
all over the campaign in my opinion that
swung a lot of voters being like dude we
talking about we're
numbers are going up um
what i assume they're thinking is
sometimes you need to take two steps
back
in order to take 100 steps forward yeah
so if
i don't think anybody wants a lockdown
anyone who's like yeah
a lockdown yay more masks yay
awesome the economy but
this just comes down to numbers if it's
going to cost us more money and more
stimulus
to keep fighting this pandemic
and the numbers just don't justify the
end zone justify the means if we have to
lock down for a month
in order to be freaking free and clear
clothing
you're cool with fortunately i'm not
saying i'm cool with it i'm saying
if these are what experts not talking
heads like us over here
experts are saying we might want to
consider listening to experts on this
obviously our gut instincts are going to
be like another lockdown oh my god
but if this is what it takes we need to
do something about this because how much
money
is the pandemic costing us because our
our
economy is not fully functional the
answers are whatever the media decides
to tell you that day
i love how people that voted for biden
tell us that covet is back
how the hell do they know are they the
doctors how do we know this guy isn't a
quack
all right by the way i'm embarrassed he
teaches at the university of minnesota i
think it is the most
harmful thing he could possibly say i
think it is
dangerous i think he should be disbarred
i think it's
terrible what he said though another
lockdown would destroy
this country i mean to to an economic
degree that i don't know if we'd be able
to get out of it for a long time and
here's the other thing too
biden is a puppet he will do what
everybody tells him to he's already been
documented to say that he would shut
down the country if science told him to
or if he was
encouraged to so can you read the tea
leaves where this is going it's headed
in exactly that direction
and and you know what do we really know
covet is back yeah positive tests are
back
are people dying more is it a fatal
disease politically are our icu
units really that overwhelming
apparently
don't go texas go all this all show all
and
if you can make that bigger kai be good
have you guys talked to doctors like in
march april may yeah
that are actually in we did go to go to
death
yeah go to death so death is not up
cases are up adam if you think about it
so
do me a favor put them side by side like
put put another page side by side so we
can go to it
to go to another page and put the same
exact search that you just put up covet
cases
just type in chronovirus cases yeah they
go like that and go to it
and then change from texas to all show
all
so so look at that so if can you make
this smaller and put it right next to
the other one because i want to compare
the two make it smaller
and make the other one yeah so so go to
covet cases cover cases so go to death
because this is how you measure this
like if the cases are up but death is
down it just means
it's not as deadly just so everybody
knows yeah go a little more left and
then and then change it from cases to
death on the left side
yeah so if you look at that can you make
that a little smaller guy or no can you
okay let's just look that's fine that's
fine the weight is okay so if you look
at this right here
this is what you see so here it went up
cases went up
so death this is cases okay cases went
up
death went up right at the beginning we
had no clue what we were doing
then death went down june 13
cases flattened okay cases went up we
had one big day
here then it's pretty much been flat
even though the cases have been going up
you don't see a spike going up so
you realize the more cases go up and
death
stays flat you know what it's saying
it's not as deadly
that's what it says i don't that makes
sense or not so if cases are going look
at look how bad
it's the worst it's ever been with cases
right look at over here it's a worse has
been with cases
but death is flat you know so if this
spikes
then that means the rate of how deadly
it is is deadly
but if cases are going up it just means
kids are going back to school september
kids started going back to school
october november you know what kids are
around each other
by the way in my house in my kids school
they just shut down high school
high school has to go home because three
kids got covered so they shut down the
whole high school
yeah so they send a high school home in
texas to private school
but everybody else is still going to
school but high school because they're
playing around they're together they're
playing sports whatever they're doing
they shut it down right so
but you know the data doesn't show more
people are dying i'm i'm making your
shows we're getting more kicks i get it
i get it i get
my question what i'm saying is this what
would you rather have
we shut down we don't shut down gdp
grows at
you know two percent right yeah
we shut down for a month gdp grows
at 10 percent what would you rather have
that's not a
realistic option well how's the gdp
going to grow
on over a lockdown i i don't think
that'd be like saying would you like to
have a lot uh
but you're guaranteed to have a winning
lottery ticket or would you rather not
have that well the gdp
lockdown is bad no other way around it
gdp in the second quarter
went down 34 right
it went back up 35 and q3
my question is if we lock down but gdp
is able to grow
because they get a hold of this no no no
gdp doesn't grow if you lock down gdp
only grows
if you send free money out that's how we
grow okay so we're going into more
there's going to be another
package it's not going to get approved
the senate is owned on the other side
there's still going to be a stimulus
package that's just the same
as you think not the size it would be at
least a trillion dollars yeah eight
hundred million
trillion dollars yeah okay but all i'm
saying is
if experts not talking heads like us
over
you're saying that a potential lockdown
you're forgetting these are not
listen just so you know lockdown
benefits me
let me tell you selfishly so a lockdown
benefits me tremendously
more money in the stimulus benefits me
tremendously in millions of ways
we had the biggest month in the history
of the company when there was lockdown
selfishly it benefits me but it crushes
restaurants
it crushes small businesses do you know
how hard so so let me give you a little
bit more perspective
so you know when you start a business
how hard is it to keep a business
running
and flowing you know how hard it is very
hard very hard you know what's even
harder
when you go out of business and try to
start another one when your business
goes out of business
what's your next move what's the first
thing you do when your business goes out
goes out of business
what's the first thing you got to do try
another one i guess no you get a job
you go get a job to save money because
all your savings was in that business
so the only reason you went out of
business because you ran out of money
if you have money you would have never
ran out of business yeah but these
businesses that are operating at 50
capacity yeah okay what if they continue
to operate at 50
capacity if you shut down they're done
their margins are so expensive
not if there's ppp with your stimulus
how much stimulus you're going to give
them to stay in business
if it's for a month i've been looking at
office space left and right you know
what landlords have been saying
we're given 25 discount for people that
are struggling
25 they're not saying hey it's okay it's
25 25
the other business that took a big hit
his business didn't take a 25
hit the other guy took an 80 hit so you
took an 80
head on revenue and profits but you're
getting a 25 savings on the lease you
got to pay
you're out of business buddy such basic
stuff what kind of business are they
possibly doing at 50
capacity let's just let's because you're
desperate you need any kind of money
to try to stay afloat and you're trying
to make your business stay alive
with your savings your life savings
you're saying you're one okay you're
saying if there's one month
of lockdown yeah i'm posing a question
and they give you money they give you
money they're not giving you enough
money 800 billion is nothing
you're saying 800 billion they're saying
it could be 1.5 trillion that's nothing
to who though what do you mean to
everybody a lockdown is a horrible thing
how do you keep a business going on bro
for one month here guys we're not
talking about for six months
do you really believe shutting down the
country is a good thing
right now i mean literally airlines got
crushed
good news we got vaccines coming up
stocks went up it's good
people are excited phenomenal you want
to shut down for four to six weeks
and by the way you know how you shut
down the economy for 90 days
you know how you shut down the economy
for 90 days guess how you shot down the
economy for 90 days
first you convince people to agree to
four to six weeks that's how you shut
down the economy for 90 days do you
understand what i just said
here's how you do it you're saying it's
a slippery slope no no here's how you do
it you shut down economy for 46 weeks
but the case is all stirred there we
need to go we're almost there
let's go four more weeks yeah that's
what they did last night that's exactly
what's happening in california that's
what they do every single week and every
single month man i'm not
saying we should do it i know you're
saying if the numbers know what you're
doing
tom you know who also doesn't know you
you're saying it's all a matter of yeah
but i can't
i can't control myself when someone is
advocating to shut the country down
it makes no sense i'm i'm uh i'm i'm
i'm with you tremendously on not doing
that i think what needs to happen look
when we're having a conversation about
new york what'd you say
you gave perspective your perspective
was what you wanted your grandma to die
okay you don't want your grandmother to
die if they come to thanksgiving so what
did i say
let's say are you guys still gonna have
the gatherings maybe you don't know
about your grandma
maybe you go to the grandma and check on
them and you leave right maybe some
people are not going to do that so the
grandpa
like the other day tico was sick okay
he had a flu 100 degrees he likes to
sleep with his papa
i when i say you're not sleeping with
papa tonight he says why not that's
because your dad
democrat can be involved in individual
people's lives
that benefits them a shutdown is
beneficial
to them for that reason for what how
does it get elected
because they're more dependent on the
government they'll want the stimulus
they'll want
everything that the big government wants
to provide for you is what they think
that they'll need
so you're saying that he wants to do
that so people are more dependent on
government
it has nothing to do with actually i
don't think biden wants to have a
shutdown i'm asking
you don't think there's any part of this
that he wants to actually control the
virus here's the last thing i would say
if the i'm not saying the virus isn't
out there i'm not saying it's not
bad for people that are susceptible to
it do we do you know anyone personally
who has died from it i do
i know a 91 year old a 90 year old i
don't know anybody other than really
really
extremely old people and i don't know
anybody that it has really
truly affected their day-to-day phone
system is offline right now
so but that doesn't affect this okay got
it okay
got it so look i i don't know what's
gonna happen i don't know what this is
all about i mean people cannot we'll
figure it out
thank god we have but you know dr zenner
over here to enlightenment you know
youtube had huge issues yesterday yeah
they had huge issues they're having
issues that's all good i mean it's all
good we had people this was great
dialogue hopefully we'll get a chance to
upload this and put the short clips and
get people to be able to hear this
conversation because this was a great
conversation we had here today
um you probably cannot hear this but for
those of you that can hear it
when we re-upload this if you enjoy
today's dialogue
click on that subscribe button if you
got any thoughts about what we talked
about comment below we actually read
your comments
and with that being said have a
wonderful week and a weekend take care
everybody bye bye bye
you